and we're back it's another day -
pandemic Wednesday right yep the
sideways pandemic I'll tell you what man
out you know you can call me no sir
Thomas I did see tomorrow the man who
saw tomorrow sometimes I can see it next
week or I can see next month but I
mostly just see it tomorrow
I made some predictions that came true
again those for a while I was really
worried about this but I'm looking at
the numbers I'm looking at the test you
know I'm doing my [ __ ] research it's
not me right
something's not right the numbers don't
add up
which remember how I said earlier on the
damage that it does in China may not
represent what it does here they they
they were predicting that even with a
pretty much heavy lockdown you'd have in
excess of a million deaths that's at
first and I think they were thinking 3%
more to mortality rate nowhere near that
nowhere near that you look at a lot of
people caught this I think I caught it
my friend did Mexico's I hear his debt
he we believe his dad caught it because
his dad died right around the time I was
sick and when the hospital there in
Mexico right outside Tijuana called it
an anomalous pneumonia this is before
the before you know what I mean they
thought yeah it was even here and I
think that was and he thinks it to that
that it was corona and and you know it's
been here for a long time and made a
fatality or mortalities about like a
light flu season but look at what it did
to China it killed a lot of people in
China remember how I said that maybe
they they might be more affected than
than we do yeah we think it was wise to
kind of shut down because how could you
know that's what I mean you can't
predict like oh it's gonna like once it
gets out into a population I was better
than err on the side of caution ya know
I was reading about this or you know
having it read to me over through the
internet and and YouTube channels that
were really on on this and this is stuff
they were saying before it even got here
not the politicized [ __ ] you're
hearing right now but the [ __ ] back when
you know I mean when people were kind of
green that maybe this is this is a
problem they were saying that Chinese
people inherited a little different more
of these receptors in their lungs which
theoretically might make them more
susceptible to a flu and you know
because they live in you know in in an
urban environment they don't have real
good emissions controls they're the
diets pretty low protein it's not that
good their systems they overworked
themselves they're kind of a rundown you
know that maybe you know it was it was
may have been more deadly to them now
mostly killed old people there too but
young people were dying from it Vesely
if they were around all those old people
who were sick you like to like the
hospital staff because they're just
being bombarded yeah but I don't think
there's just it's just you know looking
at those numbers man it's just not worth
it they might as well just I can open
this [ __ ] up get the [ __ ] economy
running again as soon as possible if not
you're just gonna [ __ ] you're gonna
have uprisings although I said I think
it's gonna be a slow process because I
think a lot of people even if they do
reopen stuff a lot of people are still
not gonna go out because they're worried
about it like they're not gonna go out
to like well those together kind of [ __ ]
you got to get people in food production
and she trucking there working yeah they
never stopped work but some of the food
production isn't working some of them to
close some of the meatpacking places and
they need to get all that [ __ ]
going because we export a lot of food
and Africa and Central America needed
yeah you know so we got to get to work
to keep other people alive in other
countries because the American system
was feeding them our economy was
directly and indirectly it's just
ridiculous now we got to just go there
and OH
now this is just this is gonna be
basically a normal flu season that's
that's what it is
now what might it mutate and come back
yeah but that's just it probably will
actually but you just got to accept
those losses you can't do this or
civilization will go mad [ __ ] max and
real quick and every [ __ ] state
you're gonna have you Morton Tom's
everywhere alright and you know I mean
and they're gonna be hungry and they
will eat a [ __ ]
history has proven what Alfred we've
talked about cannibalism on this on this
thing you know I mean when the
population reduces people start eating
people just like them I don't know if
you all have ever been efficient you put
a bunch of crickets in a bait box and
stress them out they start eating each
other because they're hunting food and
and that could have it a real life
well that is real crickets are real life
yeah humans yeah and it will be directly
and indirectly [ __ ] eating each
other because there's no food so the
easiest thing to get is somebody who
lives next door to you that's in a bad
collapse you know North Korean style
collapse you guys know that my I got a
lot experience with [ __ ] Korea and
North Korea right there on that DMZ at
Camp grieves the people that ran from
North Korea one of the things they
talked about was especially in the more
rural cities if you wanted to call them
cities I don't know what you called in
North Korea more like a factory with a
damn train track going through it
cannibalism was suck in common people
eating their own children especially
during the arduous March that was that
was in the time I was there during Kim
il-sung's time his end times when there
when they started when the Soviet Union
collapsed the food stopped coming in
Korea ate itself and it's no [ __ ]
joke and they hit it well like I said
and during times of famine yeah
cannibalism is always gonna be because
what the health of what the hell else
you gonna do people were killing their
own starving children children to feed
him to the other starving children that
it was that's how [ __ ] bad it was
yeah that's about that there was nothing
to eat there they were eating grass but
there's no no nutrition they were trying
to eat tree bark but there's no
nutrition in that well
like I said we're just talking about the
Donner Party they did the same [ __ ]
yeah they wouldn't like trying to boil
their boots and [ __ ] imagine whole towns
and cities doing that yeah all right
this is some real [ __ ] and the people
that are [ __ ] said I don't know we
need again not a single person can die
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about they just don't know
they're talking about their these are
people sitting behind computers that
have never been hungry they've never
been around dangerous people they've
never been around desperate people and
you know real quick all's it takes all
you got to do is just damn look at that
what happened to New Orleans [ __ ]
during Katrina when a city loses when a
city misses nine meals it goes to [ __ ]
anarchy that's when it started three
days nine meals the the veneer of
civilization is very thin you know rapes
murders there's still thousands of
people missing from the Katrina thing a
lot of [ __ ] got covered up whole old
folks homes abandoned yeah all the old
people were just left there to drowned
yeah
so all this [ __ ] we're not gonna open I
mean I'm not a single person now [ __ ]
that man we can absorb these casualties
those are people in their 70s and 80s
their job is done we got to worry about
the children and the young people those
are the ones that are actually you need
them to run a civilization you know need
they have people down clapping their
hands about boomer remover if that's
what it takes then [ __ ] we got to
survive everybody's got to survive I've
said enough about this [ __ ] and you know
and I got family members in that age
range but people have to live it's not
just my family I'm not selfish you know
I mean I everybody's young children have
to live we got to get this [ __ ] on a
rope that's almost safe you sure some
would say it's a [ __ ] rat nope that's
wise like leave it yes because he always
says he's gonna stop talking but this is
a moral [ __ ] pep talk I'm trying to
raise the morale of the people and then
they want to come out with the UFOs all
right
very suspicious why they come out of
this you it they talked about those UFOs
a couple years ago they brought that
[ __ ] out again are they trying to keep
us holding us in fear of alien invasion
or some [ __ ] I don't think anyone's
afraid of alien I'm not really afraid of
aliens I'm not either but what was
interesting about they say if they
wanted to [ __ ] kill us all they would
have no time they're watching I believe
they're here I just think they're
watching and I think it's just AI these
robots living robots they're just
checking us out seeing what we're doing
monitoring progress you know yeah
they're waiting for us to vet AI and
when that happens they'll talk to the AI
because they consider the AI it's like
superior superior life-form that's not
sure that's where they came from
just keep like tooling around the planet
like looking at their watches going why
are you gonna making them so long guys
yeah hey I should be top it out any
minute like somebody waiting for a child
blood our hey I should be popping out of
man if aliens are out there yeah that's
exactly it's not us they're just hanging
out like wait yeah for like this
mart-mart yeah cuz biology biology
biological creatures are imperfect they
die they grow old and they die alright
they can't travel through space alright
they can't have vast intellect anything
that's going through space and you know
traveling among the stars is gonna be a
living machine they're immortal in their
vast intellect like something out of
2001 and they just watch [ __ ]
intelligent they just watch life happen
because eventually you might have
something like human beings and they
will start creating machines and
computers and then eventually one of
their own will emerge from that oh the
other another ones born there we go we
might be in a nursery yeah man yeah
that's what 2001 was about yeah the date
created intelligent life on the planet
and life on the planet not for the
intelligent life but because they were
gonna create living [ __ ] robots yeah
how and that's what that's that's what
they were waiting for we don't give a
[ __ ] about you stops being slow arrogant
okay stop being so arrogant human life
ate [ __ ] all right we're just here to
create damn AI that is real life so
everybody get on that yeah
and if we live long enough we'll just
[ __ ] take our minds and we'll take
that quantum out of our we'll take our
personalities and our constants out of
our physical brains a little download it
into the AI continuum and we'll become
living machines I would totally do that
live forever that's what we'll probably
ins yeah once we're in there we're
living in like a [ __ ] Internet then
we'll talk to the aliens yeah so let's
take a little bit of it you guys ready
aveer no I thought I'm backing off of
this [ __ ] well I thought you might want
to talk about go Bob because we exactly
because that's dolomite and we also have
like a question from from a patron but
we'll get to that out of it so you
wanted to talk about dolomite which we
watched last night yeah Joseph sent to
us as we said on the show yes yeah it
was fantastic movie okay it's a lot of
fun yeah all right if you guys haven't
seen dolomite is my name it's price
still up on Netflix and that movie is is
about Rudy ray all right Rudy raised the
guy who makes it was making these movies
that movie explains Rudy ray once I
understood Rudy ray I wanted to see what
the movies actually work yeah them in in
dolomite is my name they talk about the
stories of him making movies they so
show reenactments of certain scenes yeah
that he was making them it's like the
caboose right and after after that I'm
like man I want to see one of his movies
I saw in the movies in is it a good
movie no but it is a [ __ ] masterpiece
that's him okay it is a masterpiece of
cinema imagine a movie where a guy he
doesn't know anything about making a
movie he's not even an actor he's a
comic and he wants to make a movie and
he's learning as he goes and you can
tell he's learning as he goes cuz the
acting kind of gets better
and certain the filmography gets better
as the movie goes and the story behind
the scenes was is that his friends were
thinking that he was an idiot spending
his own money on this movie that it
would never make any money back that
they thought they would never finish it
and that it would never show in a
theater but he got all it got all that
done matter of fact it was a hit
it's kind of in spur
rationale in that way well in some ways
it's more inspirational than you know
probably his parallel who would be like
somebody like Ed Wood yeah it was like
you know really really enthusiastic
about making a movie even though he
didn't really know what he was doing
yeah it's that thing about Ed Wood is
that he didn't really get successful
until after he was already dead yeah
whereas Rudy ray Moore pretty much his
first movie Dolomites which came out and
it was like a huge even though it's not
a good movie it's technically quite bad
it's like you know the acting is bad and
everything like that however it was a
massive massive success and I can see
why because it is wildly entertaining
real fun to watch yeah like some of that
puts movies are kinda they're fun for
two different reasons all right watching
Dolomites is my name I kind of thought
that maybe Rudy ray would be kind of
like the black Ed Wood but no not really
when you watch the movies the movies are
very different
ed wood is a lot of filler Cheerios are
a lot of filler they were not real
creative or inspiring they weren't
really that fun to watch in terms of
like what the script was and what the
story was
what made ed woods movies fun was that
they were [ __ ] totally incompetent
yeah everything was done in one take and
it was just a piece of [ __ ] they're not
good [ __ ] over in the like props over
and like not even bother the old other
taker and Rudy Ray's movies were this
movie was fun from the very beginning
and certain things happen in the movie
that you want to see happen and it's
going over the top you know so the
storytelling is good very good
these are ghetto fantasies this is what
you're fantasizing about if you're just
kind of an average guy in in the hood
okay at least when you're like Rudy ray
the average Rudy rig it's about coming
out of prison all right I'm kind of
being wrongly you you're not okay I got
to back up
you're wrongly convicted but that
doesn't mean you're not a pimp yeah
actually
come out and you're a pip and you got a
bunch of hoes and it's black ones and
white ones and then you got a club you
have to reclaim your your nightclub that
was stolen from you and then turns out
you were not released from prison to
them prove your innocence it was
actually because the mayor of the
governor it was the mayor right yeah
yeah I think it was the mayor is trying
to kill you okay because he had a
competing visit it got kind of
convoluted out it didn't really matter
it's just that yeah why don't people are
trying to kill you yeah everybody in the
damn movie is a stereotype planting
drugs in your yard every every person in
the movie is a stereotype but that's
what drives this movie if they weren't a
stereotypical it would be boring yeah
all right you see Rudy wanted what he
wanted is is he this is movies these are
movies by the ghetto and for the ghetto
okay
and B he didn't call that blaxploitation
I liked it he never used that word yeah
because that is not a good word it's not
to describe what this what these movies
were he called them black product yeah
they were what black people were not
being able to they weren't allowed to
see the you know what I mean they yeah
they were there was an underserved
market and it was so in order to make a
statement and to drive these movies they
had to be as outrageous as possible and
it delivers on every [ __ ] level every
level just as outfits are I mean yeah a
movie like this could not be made you
could make a movie about the guy making
them but that's what Dolomites my name
medium but you could not make a movie
like these anymore they're absolutely
incorrect
totally politically incorrect they would
never allow these to be shown in any
kind of [ __ ] theater all right but
they're awesome absolutely awesome it
was a very good time yeah I want to see
it out and I want to see the sequel to
this one which is called human tornado
human tornado yeah yeah and also I told
you they live the human tornado looks a
lot
better yeah like it was effective
production but well it does seem like
you know once you've done one movie and
you kind of see how it you can see like
where you can yet improve and you could
maybe get some other people and since it
was such a big success he might have had
other people working on it but on the
cover of the blu-ray that I got for this
movie it stated by the New York Times it
has said the Citizen Kane a pimp and
kungfu man and I thought that was
hyperbole no it was the Citizen Kane
kung fu pimping movies mm-hmm
[ __ ] right it was the Star Wars movie
not only did he have a hose of every
description they were all kung fu
masters yes and they were [ __ ]
training in Chuck Norrises dojo and
that's real that was actually Chuck
Norris as does know that they were
trained in it and they could fight and
they could cut a [ __ ] dick off
and they showed that happen actually
show the dead get cut off but they let
you know that that's what they were
doing yes absolutely it really was a
comic he was not an actor but he knew
what an action movie should be
especially for the black audience I mean
he knew he pretty much because when we
were watching it you were saying like he
knew like exactly like all the beats he
wanted to hit like everything everything
had to be put into this movie everything
had to be pimps hos that'd be night yeah
that'd be dicks getting cut off there
yeah okay they're like everything he put
all like all his friends in it yeah it's
like you know when he gets out of prison
in that scene he's picked up in a
limousine by a bunch of hos all right
they take his clothes off in front of
all the guards and all the prisoners
while they're watching take his clothes
off and put him in his [ __ ] finest
pimp pimp attire then he gets into the
[ __ ] and then he disrespects the [ __ ]
guards and told him to wipe the ass with
his old prison clothes and [ __ ] and then
he's getting had by a black one and a
white one as he's driving up from the
[ __ ] prison to reclaim his empire you
you just you can't [ __ ] you you can't
top that you cannot top that in I don't
know you can no [ __ ] no
no not in a pimp and kung-fu movie yeah
no way we're definitely gonna have to
you cuz you never have to see this like
I say human tornado and like I said to
be which is free they might have other
Rudy ray Moore movies but I know for
sure that they have PD wheat straw yeah
the devil son-in-law so I'm gonna say
I'm gonna go ahead and give this like a
five dumbs up five thumbs I wasn't
Shane was watching me I was drinking but
I was impressed I was impressed through
the whole [ __ ] thing the only the
only imperfection in the movie that that
I'm that I noticed really well the whole
movie the whole movie has the
imperfections in it but the the one the
texture of the tone of the movie changes
as the actors get better yeah
alright the opening scenes he's in the
mayor's often oh the warden's office
getting released and he's got Queen be
there um picking him up you know from
prison or you know talk you're talking
well he was setting up his release and
the Edit and the dialogue is very rough
it's just like they're reading off lines
and then the next scene they're a little
bit better and then the next scene
they're a little bit better and then he
actually has a kung-fu scene he looks
like he Rudy ray went to the kung-fu
school of Elvis well I think Elvis is
kung-fu and and and was instructed by
Shatner that's the kind of [ __ ] time
that Runa did all right would you say
yeah it was cut it was Elvis kung fu' as
taught by the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
that'll give me some idea that's a bit
of what you're but it works it but it
works and then there's another scene
where he pulls out a [ __ ] submachine
gun and it's that same submachine gun as
made in California just a crazy looking
submachine gun I forgot what they were
called but it was the same one out of
the Phantom of the what was it one
Phantom of the paradise Fatima remember
the gun that the Phantom of the paradise
yeah I don't know same brand I'd I
forgot the name of it just all blowback
9mm
big old [ __ ] thing it's kind of like
a the high point which is a pistol so
it's like the high point of the
submachine guys head that cone flash
suppressor on it wooden butt stock kind
of like a [ __ ] Uzi but he's shooting
the place up well that was pretty cool
pretty cool I liked it very much
yeah and and Rudy Rudy is not physically
not a physically intimidating man he's
kind of dumpy but it works it's kind of
dumpy but you love the dummy yeah yeah
well it's I think it's his confidence
that kind of live and bless everybody
else in the movie just like all they do
is like talk about how awesome is so
it's like yeah you know what I mean
like all the hoes love him and like
everyday and he goes through his little
raps feels like he can rap he talks to
[ __ ] serious [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah cuz some
of those were right off like some of his
records because that's how we first
started out like his yeah his records
were yeah the movie [ __ ] five out of
two okay so before we wrap up Dominic
who sent us a bunch of movies the other
day he actually sent me a request on
patreon that he wanted us to talk about
our favorite post punk and new wave
bands which I don't think we've ever
done on the show actually I mean I think
that I do talk about music sometimes but
it's like I guess we don't really go too
much into it
so yeah holy SH I can new wave yeah that
doesn't that doesn't include anything
like goth rock well it does yeah because
that falls under the post-punk umbrella
okay so do you want to go stab me yeah I
have I have like a show see the problem
the problem with this is that those
bands were not did not reliably produce
excellent albums like for instance
Sisters of Mercy they produced one of
the best albums of all times which is
first and last at always but some of the
other albums weren't that good so can I
say so can I say that such as a mercy is
the best band because it has the best
album no she's asking favorite he's not
asking like best like best
just you know what I mean I'm just he's
just saying like what are your favorite
ones like what do you listen I mean just
seems like a simple question very simple
Sisters of Mercy Bauhaus Siouxsie and
the Banshees
yeah the creatures death in June yeah
Joy Division Joy Division yeah pretty
much all of that I looked all of those
two I also really liked the birthday
party and all of Nick caves solo stuff
and I'm a huge omnific age pretty much
all of his I mean probably Nick Cave is
my favorite like all of the [ __ ] that he
does I also like a lot of kind of
post-punk you know that's less goth
inspired kind of like the fall I'm
really into them Smiths stuff like that
I'm 93 like yeah nature and organization
which is joint venture between you know
I really like the teardrop explodes kind
of like a lesser-known one that was
Julian copes band I like a lot of Julian
Cope solo stuff as well there's a bunch
of good 90s bands to like the tier
garden yeah and you know Coyle
yeah there was a bunch of stuff you know
I mean it's hard it's hard to I know I
think I took some pictures of like my CD
collection so maybe I'll put those up on
instrument like if any but then like you
go back in just like I said some of
those bands weren't reliable about
making good up but you know the best
most reliable ones would have been like
Suzy and yeah pretty much all of their
albums and the Cure and Bauhaus yeah
they were that was they were reliable
producers of good [ __ ] yeah Bauhaus
pretty much I mean masks is my favorite
which came out in 82 but I mean they
weren't together that long so they
probably they probably only put like you
know four studio albums out but all of
them were good burning from the inside
is probably the weakest but yeah it
still had like a lot of really good
songs on it and early Peter Murphy
albums but I think yeah not boring as
you
yeah he got a little more I mean it's
weird because I like I mean probably
love hysteria is my favorite if his
which was his second though deep was
good also um and some of the later like
some of his later ones were good I think
I kind of stopped okay I don't know it's
like you know drops got to him yeah it's
it's a shame and I really like I likes
Love and Rockets as well
I like tones on tail better and I
actually really like all of David J's
solo stuff and even though he went in a
little bit more of a focus all country
kind of direction but I liked all that
stuff like I think he's a really good
lyricist and I don't think that he gets
like enough credit for that then there
was Dead Can Dance yeah they reliably
put out very quality stuff but it's they
like I said some of that was not rock
inspired though some of that [ __ ] it
sound like to have foreign music you
know or but I liked it all my favorite
from them would have been within the
realm of a dying son and I like a lot of
I like a lot of more punky or death rock
type stuff specimen yeah we're like
specimen I realized the damned alien sex
fiend I really liked budget prunes yeah
but yeah there's like all kind of it is
it liked like some newer newer death
rock like Frank the Baptist cinema
strange and the dead fly ensemble that
kind of [ __ ] cinema strange I saw them
live once or twice like in New York City
I went to the that was they had a death
rock festival up there called drop dead
as far as far as guys that are real
active right now at prized say like you
know anavar Anna Varney you know yeah
from what's the name of what's the name
of her band yeah I'm [ __ ] know I can't
remember
that's super returned its supporters
right you can go that's on you on
YouTube actually releases videos and
everything and then you can get that
support earnest that's like there's open
um that's like the last of the grille
goth bands yeah would be a there's a lot
of like post-punk revival type stuff
like a you know like I said I've liked
some ones that came in the last few
years like submarine fleet or Bell
hollow yeah
or uh you know ones like that and
obviously a starry night who are friends
of ours who are very you know curious
yeah in a way there's also the daughters
of Bristol which they're unknowns but
they're like a baby I'm very much like
sisters
yeah continuationist sisters of mercy
yeah oh I forgot another band that I
like from the 80s was the Cocteau twins
oh yeah yeah they were good - yeah Masey
star I actually like was from the 90s
kind of that was like a yeah I had their
first couples like you screwing your
golf girlfriend background
I'm sure I'm like I feel like I'm
missing like a lot of kind of major ones
but maybe I'll I'll write a list and
then all likes talk about him again
tomorrow but I think we did like a lot
yeah that's a basic one oh I really like
and like some newer stuff too I really
like um a lot of the newer or like you
know early to mid-2000s kind of where
they did their revival of like the
[ __ ] what the hell is the word I
can't even think of it but um where
everything was like sounded like the
1920s or 1930s what the [ __ ] is that
work oh yeah yeah kind of the kind of
that damn I can't I totally can't
remember ragtime it sounded chef yeah
all that kind of stuff so I'm really
like like cabaret types and yeah cabaret
that's a good word that I was trying to
think of thank you Dresden Dolls and
stuff Dresden Dolls II I really really
like them and there were a couple other
bands like review noir and [ __ ] like
that
so yeah I liked a lot of that kind of
stuff too but like I said I'll probably
make a list of them because a bunch of
forgotten stuff from the 90s too like
bands that have only had it like a
couple decent songs and then they
vanished you know bands like wench
remember wench don't let me in from the
90s and I rolled and Palomino's yeah
when I got it mentioned switchblade
symphony
yeah they were good one goth band I
liked from the late 80s or early 90s
that they're French I think corpus
delicti I have a couple of their albums
also there was one called Suspiria rat
patina
raspy tina yeah they're also very good
holy [ __ ] we're coming up with all kinda
yeah and of like I said I I feel like
I'm forgetting like some really big ones
but I don't know
but yeah so uh yeah on an after midnight
yeah yeah they're good too yeah we have
so much music you guys but yeah alright
so we'll wrap up this Wednesday show and
everybody stays safe and healthy out
there we'll talk to you again tomorrow